there is a really rough crime story out
right now
i don't focus on individual crime
stories too often but this one is pretty
pretty sick stuff joel arseniega sainz a
25 year old
illegal alien i was indicted by a grand
jury this week because he was
arrested for murdering 51 year-old james
garcia in new mexico the day after
father's day
he decapitated garcia then mutilated the
rest of his body
and then started kicking his head around
like a soccer ball
the reason i bring it up is not just the
gruesome details it's because at the
time of the murder
arcianega sans was out on bail he had
previously been arrested
and they just let him out on bail
because you see we need criminal justice
we need the first step back we need a
second step act we need to let the
we need to let these people out of
prison we need to abolish prisons darn
it
that's what i've been told prisons are
the modern day slavery
is what i've been told then the problem
is when you let out the prisoners
right when you let out the criminals
they um decapitate people and kick their
heads around like soccer balls do you
think that's good do you think it's for
justice
do you think that's increasing equality
and flourishing
and liberty in the country i don't think
it is i don't think it is at all
i noticed this yesterday bill cosby got
out on a technicality you saw that
and everyone was complaining about this
fair enough but i thought we were
supposed to abolish prisons
i thought we were i thought there were
too many black men in prison remember
that's what we were
explicitly in a racial appeal prisons
are the new jim crow or something
black man got out of prison isn't that
good well no it's bad why is it because
it's bill cosby
but if we abolish prisons we have
nowhere to put bill cosby
even if we got to keep him in jail the
theory
of this that what we're being told in
theory and sold in theory
seems a little bit different when you
read the stories of guys kicking
people's heads around or rapists going
free or whatever
whatever you want to read science is
dead
and we have killed it that's the name of
this episode you like that clip go check
out the whole episode here on youtube
you can subscribe you can like you can
go check it out on apple podcast spotify
google play and stitcher and you can
order
my number one nationally best-selling
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds
this was number one top of the
nonfiction charts last week thanks to
you so glad people are engaging with the
book
hope you like it as well we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you